hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Saucon today we're sitting
down with Manuel Frederic and root is
ba' we're talking about connect their
project and I fell in love with it from
the first second that I saw these guys
and the activity that they were doing to
share what they're bringing to the world
and it's peace through connectivity yeah
human connectivity through human
connectivity let's let's show the let's
start with a human connectivity moment
with click so there is really the center
of our philosophy our project our
mission our movement that we created and
it is really all about this this moment
the human touch the connection
and you mentioned when we talked earlier
about you said it's it's is it about
slowing down people and that's not
necessarily the goal to slow down people
but necessarily you have to take a
little bit more time to to have the
connection to have like to acknowledge
each other to look at each other and to
feel each other and so we decided like
you're almost two years ago after you
know all the messing around the world
like the immigrant creases the terrorist
attacks the fact that we are all
connected on devices but so disconnected
in the real world to say okay let's do
something simple something that you
don't need money you don't need a lot of
things to create peace so we started
like with this gesture and it's quickly
it's turned to this you know and we
start to use a new technology so you
take your cell phone like that because
we're all about also using the new
technology yes and so then you connect
like that with one cell phone with one
cell phones and their share one and then
you take oh you take us oh okay and then
through say
that's it and then host with hashtag
connect yeah this was their first action
1 million selfies well peace when aliens
selfies for peace and then we were doing
the same after like but with a bigger
group you know yeah exactly and your
drone shots are amazing I love those it
is all I think in order to change the
world it is all about changing
perspective if you want to change
something yet something is different you
have to be a little bit crazy you have
to think out of the box you have to go
other ways than the ways people are used
to correct correct and so that's that's
why we're trying to combine things like
the selfie everybody does selfie said no
how many million selfies are posted each
day yeah that is a lot but how many of
them are about connecting yeah we don't
even follow up too much a few thousands
yeah that's look that's the question is
how many of them are slowing down and
human a human connectivity and peace I
would say very few right now are about
those things many are about vanity
themselves nurse yeah people in general
and that's interesting because what you
just said about about being focused on
ourselves and being in our own little
space actually you can find that in our
gesture as well because this is
something almost everybody knows in
every culture it's it is either prayer
it is namaste
it is in Japan it's a gesture that is
globally known for whatever reason it is
and even even if I look at this we have
we have the palm so there must be some
magic about that our card coasters have
they have the same thing the hand at
home the palm out yeah yeah and there's
there's something special about the palm
yeah there's something very special
about these these hands and how they do
those things for us and how they are all
of these prints completely different
from what yes snowflake you know very
special things about it so this this
gesture is all about being in a piece
being aligned with the divine whatever
the divine it is but it's all about all
about this it's all about me
me being calm me being connected with
the ground but it's about me this
creating that let's create that again
we're creating the same gesture it is
the same gesture we creating right here
and the Spirit is the same but it's not
about me it is about me and that's the
collectiveness and that's what we want
to want to achieve that's like the end
goal so to speak to have a collective
conscious of people all around the world
all around the universe of thinking not
me but me yeah and then we come to
things like sharing like why don't you
smashing what do you use me instead of
awesome the second one because I want
this because we're living in a world of
me so people understand me but I want
them to understand that the me feeling
we want to have it collectively as
feeling we have to create the earth
spinning at one point you're going to
have the US but people understand me
very quickly okay yeah okay i phone me
because you have to understand what so
like we came from a century like if we
like go back like two century before it
was like industrialization like we need
to go faster we need to grow faster like
all the societies so it was like the
time of like let's say the to be like
really quick you know the time of like
everything I need to even fast you know
get rid of the the the the horse and
everything let's have cars and stuff and
then we switch from this
industrialization period
everything was need need to go fast even
if we district all the all the planet to
the psychology period yeah so to further
and to all these people whose develop a
lot of me you know of like okay you need
to analyze yourself and it was a lot
based on like you moi in French it's
like the ego you know and so yeah the
more the meat wah the more is Emir and
it's in and so we developed to
understand more a way you know and
nowadays you have a lot of people who
know a lot about themselves you know or
know a lot about them thinking but they
don't care about others they have their
pieces they go to yoga they love their
family their kids but they don't know
their neighbor you know so it's always
you know now I think we go to the to the
century of spirituality yes and
spirituality it's about not ego but
spiritual you know just about soul and
when you talk about soul we talk about
to be connected
we all will resent like one for all we
are all one yes but like the soul the
spiritual the spirit - it's not
something like only just me on the
ground it's like something to the sky so
it's like having everybody but being
also one you know so I'm one for all and
we are all for one you know so I will
ask you guys about that later because I
want to know about the balance between
having ego and being able to build
something into the world and focusing on
that while also having erratic full
eradication of ego so that we can feel
the whole us to me the collective means
and how to balance how you guys think is
good to balance that before we go there
let's talk more about the connecting
movement so started to two years ago yes
and so tell us initially how did you
guys meet and where did the whole like
aha let's do connect it was like that it
was really like yeah yeah it was two
seed and we both artists both filmmakers
both both people that are very I would
say sensitive sensible we feel when
things are a little bit wrong yeah as a
lot of artists do so yeah and we chose
filmmaking is our passion and our our
work and we met that the can film
festival in I think 2013 first I know
which one the income income in France
and France which is in C 14 or 20 2013
13 years 13 OH
and as we're both attending or had or
were you already filmmaking
working on teams or your own I had a
shelter team over there you didn't cause
yeah I had friends that were going over
there and say okay I'm Oh me I want to
move to Hollywood let's go to can
because that's where everybody yeah
everybody good Sam
okay and then we kind of like and it was
interesting we always ended up at the
same parties the same events we didn't
even know each other but really quickly
over the two weeks that we had we got to
know each other because we were always
at the same so there must have been
something that was attracting us to the
same things yes and later on we
exchanged contact information we kept in
touch and then I think two years later
we actually rented an apartment together
in kin-por Oh in Collin can you do the
physical festival together okay cool
yeah and when we started working
together it was funny or so because you
know like when you go and can it's a lot
like everybody have like you have people
with lot of money like people they will
go to can just to rent a spot car
because this cost them like thousand and
thousand just to go there yeah and to be
like I'm the most beautiful person in
the world which is not it is just your
car is beautiful you know and what
what's up here always what's up yeah
yeah you know what I mean yeah how you
are willing to give yes you know what do
you have and what do you will you
willing to lost well give you know yeah
compared to what you have if you have a
lot of course you can give a lot but if
you're not have if you have a little and
you give a lot that's it
the real change yeah yeah so we am
hoping this can is really interesting
because you have both worlds you have
some of the greatest artists that come
and they black are grouped together in a
little little city in a little spot for
like two weeks
so you meet hundreds of interesting
people that you get collaborated with on
the other hand you have so much money so
much wealth so many power people that
that mingle with those with the famously
rich and famous so this creates a
special energy and like I think it's
kind of like an interesting image of the
world where you have
on one hand you have creative people on
the other hand you have power people and
you have just in in one at one time in
the same spot is very as a great and it
kind of sounds like the French Burning
Man a little bit yeah I think it's it's
like that you know yeah people in
Burning Man will come from nature and
there lots of stuff and then people
who's going to come only to make the
barrio and then the orange there is like
people to do their business filmmaking
and then people the art is the common
ground ya know but you would find that
in all different type of like industry
like even in publicity or commercial and
finance you will find this kind of okay
of like the work and the other obvious
people who's like I have a lot I'm gonna
spend maybe like twenty thousand just to
on my table tonight
yeah did you did you did you decide to
submit a film in two thousand fifteen or
sixteen together so what happened is
like we met in 2013 but then we you know
it was not the first moment that we said
okay let's work together it's like a
kind of a diva which we call that now
that kind of the divine order sometimes
you end up in places you meet people
where you are either enough clever or
enough connected to some things around
you yeah to say well signs are not only
for fools
you know signs may be a road yeah and I
think we were both connected in this
kind of belief yeah and we were like a
man like it's been two years like I go
there you are here I'm going here you go
there and no like and then it was
interesting because we ended up to rent
this apartment but we were not we're not
really poor but still will not switch
kids you know horse so we ended up to
rent this apartment at the beginning we
were like we were like it's supposed to
be three we ought to be six you know
people six people in the same place for
a say ever places there yes they
the couch and people was sleeping in the
share from the on the chair you know
like because we were a lot about like we
didn't have a lot you know but it was
friend people well me when I was in
candy for open doors yeah and you know
you end up to be like the the people
while the lesson can and then you still
give you know and it's at the end I had
to pay something we're broken or some
stuff like that you know but it's it's
just to give you a little part of their
philosophy I would say also is about we
all have something that somebody else
need and it's it's not always about
money yeah it can be advice it can be a
smile a good moment you know oh it's a
place to sleep whatever it is but we all
have something that somebody else needs
and that is all about passing it on
sharing and and collaborating we're
gonna come to collaborating a bit later
yes is the suppose end up submitting
something together because you lived
there two years together now we didn't
we did kind of so many two weeks a year
the exactly so you didn't work on a film
to get we worked on a TV series on a TV
show what was that about what was it
about so the TV series was about love
about love and you guys didn't have this
yet no no it was really before like it's
interesting because I was working on
this TV series about love during one
year enough and traveling all around the
world with that and then when I made
that when you well again because like I
saw him and then we stopped to talk you
know and exchange you know but you know
there is some people you you say one ID
and then you'd like find some I talk to
you and I said hey you know what I wrote
this book and it's talking about to be
sad in a world that we are all together
and then he said like together to be sad
all you're talking about this book and
then how you read this book oh and it's
like it's like playing tennis yeah yeah
but we start with someone who give back
the bow the ball because more of the
time you put you you have
friends or your coworker you stop you
give the ball and I love how you just
brought that analogy to life because my
one of my close friends Jackson and I we
call it playing intellectual tennis we
can't we hit the ball over and then the
other one adds their own spin
yeah and hits it back over and we keep
playing tennis sometimes you run into
tennis players when you hit the ball
over instead of saying you know you said
oh I just came back from France they'll
say oh cool mm-hmm they stopped the
converses what were you doing in France
so you know it's just interesting how
you brought that analogy up on it's
funny because at the same time Andrew
said pink ponies at tennis yes which is
the same concept that's a different
description and that describes very well
our collaboration we think alike in the
same direction yeah but from different
angles and that's that's like light you
know when you when you focus it on and
through a prism for example then it gets
a certain strength and forth that you
wouldn't have if you're just on your own
yes now what where is the love
documentary film is that available so
it's the TV series about love and then
we start to work together closely is
that available online no no it's still
in development here because it's a TV
series like yeah let's think about
Breaking Bad or game of throne
yeah but a love version of that okay
with the dark side about mix it Kippur
and it's an airline company who's like
narrated this stories all around the
world of different mix that Cooper you
know and it's a lot about diversity it's
a lot about a global world that we're
living in us we're the result of two
people that came together to have
children there are from completely
different cultures two completely
different places on this planet but
we're the result of that yeah and that's
what the future is going to look like
we're not gonna think about are you
Jewish are you
what religion are you like are you white
I don't like to talk about colors but it
will not our cultural differences will
enrich us because they do yeah and they
will not divide us anymore and I
strongly believe in that but we have to
we still we still that not at the
beginning but we still have a lot of
work to do as as collective human
community so we about thirteen thirteen
a pizza okay for the 52 minutes
Wow it should be that even different
country what makes it cool we don't talk
only about black and white of course you
have Moroccan with South Korea yes like
a white from Norway with white from
Argentina you know straight correct
exactly different generations yeah you
have love the French president his wife
was like I think 20 years old or
something like that oh wow yeah I
believe love has no borders you know
borders we believe also like we
exploring the question of like does love
need to hurt you know does it need to
hurt that you need to hurt why it's
hurting you know like I like that it's
all the old driving of this like do we
use love us to hear ourselves or to
district to ourselves you know do you do
about a god of love
yeah oh do you believe the love is evil
do you also talk about is love with one
person yeah the only pod is about I
think you're like I've fallen in love
with earth and humanity and animals and
plants and that's my thing is trying to
help solve a lot of what is going on
especially the ones that are very
serious challenges for humans so ok this
is good as when is it released so it's
still in development the workerle title
is air loved one so you can air love why
don't one you know one thing that also
we have in common is we think big yes so
shoot for the stars you know and so we
want it to be a big series on Netflix or
HBO why
season 13 episodes when is that out one
year so it's it's in need one millions
at least for the pilot we could do it in
large edges to make it fast but it's
still a budget of 1 million like between
you know Game of Thrones when if you
draw that one you shot at or no no no
we'd shot like a trailer but we go
before taste what would board you know
like just to have like the visual style
and we made different producer producer
all around the world like we made with
Netflix HBO or like some some people
like that but not always see the Bible
and all like okay the pilot but then
connect happens like a story right they
can happen at the same time too right
yes they're very synergistic you know
when it's happen you know we were
talking about love we have this
different conversation about crazy love
district-level all the different facet
of love and bomb in the city of love
Bataclan all the terrorist attack like
five different first terrorist attack
the same night more than 160 people dead
I'm not sure exactly about the course re
but it was really like the city of love
it's not the city of love only for
French people like everybody all on the
world wants to have the only morning in
Paris you know so when you attack the
sea of love you attack humanity you can
attack the hope you know yeah and this
with the same know at the same time in
in Europe and especially in in Germany
was the biggest migration of of people
that needed help since World War two the
biggest migration of immigrants happened
with the immigrant crisis and you felt a
shift you felt there is a shift there's
something wrong in this world and it
wouldn't have to be we have so much we
have so much technology is so advanced
in medical research in in scientific
research and so many things but then you
have hundreds of thousands of people
that to flee their country because they
can't live there anymore because they're
prosecuted and so that felt like hey
there's something is shifting in this
world and it's
it's going the family it felt like
really a plane talking about planes that
is it's going down and it's it's not
functioning well and like at some point
it will crash it's really because you
know what one of the slogan when our
like we were doing this TV series like
is only you can prevent a crash only you
you know that's why we said like a no no
no we can't stay doing the TV series and
doing our movie and this and that and
nothing happened in real you know
because it's good and ten months it's
make you dream it's made you some time
analyze the reality why when you not
will be able in your own life but like
we said like no we wanted to do
something in a real we wants to inspire
people to do the same thing together you
know we all have a different ID
different point of view but just one
gesture for all we are all one through
this gesture through this yes you just
say the song and that was the moment
when in both of us there was this switch
like only you can do it only so I can do
it I have a response I have it I have
the power to do something I can do some
we have two hands I have a brain I have
a body I have a certain education I can
I can do things you know I can move
things I can impact things yes and but
let's use I have to do something that's
which in both of us was turned over and
we're like hey we have to inspire other
people to just switch on that switch and
that's what that's about so so there's a
couple things the first thing that I
thought was really interesting is that
you guys have been talking about what
has been going on in the world in terms
of terrorist attacks and that kind of
thing in the immigrant crises so what is
interesting is over time societies
become less violent right over time and
that's very good and very important but
with access to all the new technologies
it'll seems like there's new ways to be
violent in different ways and so that's
also creating this kind of important
conversation that we need to have about
about how to keep technologies working
with humanity really well and not
enabling people to do things that hurt
humanity but then also the other thing
was okay so then you guys figured out
that okay now with this happening we're
gonna start this this movement to
connect the movement and then the so the
first step was this selfie you do that
you do this you take the selfie that was
the first step and then yeah you know
the philosopher Amos is there a mrs. as
a French philosopher born in Martinique
and he talked about the concept of
miraculous weapon so the selfie we
couldn't really say it's a weapon but
it's still destructive in somehow you
know like someone who's like always
making the selfie sometimes people are
sad you know people had people had sad
they wants to cry and instead of crying
and having a picture of them crying yeah
they would say like so like they
constrict a perfect image of themselves
of themselves so we decided to use this
selfie but for the greater good here
yeah inject humanity you know touch
someone real area talking about Emmys is
there I would like to talk about
something that we all very much about is
our patron and godmother there's an
taozi who we met shortly after we
started the movement and who gave us a
lot of hope and inspiration that we
actually we're able to change the world
it's people who change the world as our
normal people like you and I and you and
you over there yeah and so she was the
the only woman who directed Marlon
Brando she did a movie about apartheid
during the apartheid risking her life
yes doing it and she's one of the she
was voted one of the 18 18 most
influential women in Hollywood so she
made history with her work as a
filmmaker and we also want to make
history and changing the world so that's
talking about we always say the three
cornerstones of what we do is unity in
diversity unity and controversy finding
common ground even if we disagree and
unity of generations so learning from
generations that have created things
before us is very important to implement
that in our thinking our life not saying
everything that's that's all this
outdated no no you should implement the
human knowledge that we have and and use
it yes this actually like lady is one of
you know one of her mounter but also
like she also remind me how much you
know she she I mean she's like at the
top of the world of Hollywood I mean she
Matt Damon give gave her a hug she was
like many time going to work with very
possible all these people but like when
you see her in the street she can like
if if a little kid code to her you know
she will take if the kid needs ten
minutes if indeed she got a lot of a
partner after she will take ten minute
yeah yeah before all elderly people is
interesting or talking will want to talk
you need ten you need twenty minutes you
have to cancel all the meeting after
with big big production and be many
people manatee first you know and she's
very humble and very grounded and so
she's very aware of what's happening
around her and it doesn't matter if
you're a superstar if you're or if you
are a homeless person yeah if people
have every person has a certain energy
yeah yeah every personal to have a
certain need as injuries and wounds and
and you can if you aware you can feel
that and you feel a person and if you
feel a person needs time then you if
you're mhm
generous enough you you give that time
yeah and but sometimes timescales in
different ways as well the time that you
can invest actually going to the meeting
that you needed to go to could
potentially impact 300 or 3,000 people
down the line so there's all these
different variables that go into the
conversation so alright let's lead us
into I want to get there but one last
thing about connect is where is the
vision going for so let's summarize what
is connect it's like what we call a
movement the war wine movement because
now it's
like stop to be global and we want to
travel off a seven continent and spread
this philosophy of human connectivity so
really simple
what is human connectivity it's like the
bridge between humanity and connectivity
so the bridge between what is defined
the most and what is the one of the most
essential need and we tend to forget is
the human touch if babies don't have the
human touch the die is like it's have
been proved by scientific Russians like
the human the human touch it is a human
need you know so we wants to overcome
differences through the human touch but
also use this connectivity world and use
it for the good using formality you know
so this is a kind of a bridge between
humanity and connectivity so we call
human connection this is the gesture
behind the philosophy talking about
changing the world I just want to put a
spotlight on where are we at right now
actually with the world and it's
interesting where we have like we need
to talk about history of humanity we
have the lowest death rates we're the
most healthy with the most as a global
collective not every not all places but
in in general like as a collective yeah
we have where the most sophisticated we
are we're very advanced we're very far
forward actually but the biggest problem
that we have right now and it's really
big and it's maybe it's it's at a peak
point is fear people a lot of people
have fear and and then talking about a
terrorist attack it's horrible it is it
is but the impact it has on people
sitting in a subway and seeing someone
that looks different and thinking it
could be a terrorist because he's he's
Arabic that's that's horrible that's
cool that's that's that's killing people
without killing people you know that's
it that's killing what we talked about
that's killing love that's creating fear
is killing love and and we're at the
point where we killing a lot of love in
the world and so we are next let's say
year what's the goal in the next year or
so like it's interesting it's
interesting that you brought this
subject you know because
i watch a short movie it was exactly
about that you know like a friend of
psychic murders one of the ways Thank
You Maura to describe it when you were
describing yeah it's like Christmas
yesterday I saw a movie like he won like
a lot of price in France in some
different short movie and it's about
like the French what we don't believe
about LaBelle's us of colors but we will
talk a little bit about that but white
women who came and he was like a one
Arab came in the in the in the subway
you know in the same you know trained
then her you know and he came with a
gift bag you know but he got like a cup
and he's like that and the whole movies
about the tension and then the the some
of the the train and he's like holding
the stuff just doing nothing you know
but she's like start to be wait and
stuff and and then she was around her
and she saw she saw also all the Arab
people who looks like Muslim and stuff
and she's like and she got out of the
plane
and she got out of the the trainer and
she's like and this is the movies shock
movie stuff like that it doesn't stop
when I don't open the box no because
that's the and I think it was wonderful
because that's good it's it doesn't say
oh no it was a nice muesli which was a
nice I probably didn't have another
thing in the box and it doesn't say also
she was a bad girl she was about lazy
you know it's called it's really based
on the the I don't remember it was a I
think the cap of Schillinger like you
don't know if the cat is dead if you go
if you if you have a box you know and
you put poison and you put a cat until
you open that box yeah you know if the
cans is dead or not you know and the
society is like that you know it's fear
yeah yeah and in this yeah this is trust
this is trust there start to feel yer
yeah you might be touched by what I do
if I like if like we didn't do a lot we
come to random strangers and we and we
go like that
you're so much more trusting yeah and
that's what we need it's also
interesting how when I saw you guys
doing that World's Fair that some people
wouldn't give you the time yeah it's so
you're so fast-paced nowadays that's
like what do you what do you mean you
put your hand up there so and then this
is that bass so it was yeah okay and
just like it clear like fear is one
thing but if this woman who came into
the train and sees a guy was be able to
talk to him because of this gesture
because we created a bridge human
connectivity yeah and she could say hi
how are you yeah what is the gift for
yeah yeah he will answer so yeah Julia
you need take a scavenge actually you
know this is for my my daughter I didn't
saw it in three months I just came back
from the Army I know yeah but of course
you need to know the unknown approaches
yeah yeah but like it's it's really
called unity yeah and before all the
stories attack because we didn't stop to
think about changing the world for the
better because of the terrorist attack
it will make no sense you know we
decided because since I think we are
like really young we kind of fear a feel
that there is a fear because of the lack
of unity because when you don't know
someone and you can put so you know know
someone so if you don't know someone how
you can put yourself in the other shoes
they of course you know yeah and it for
us like and the peace building process
is really about putting yourself in
their shoes yeah but when your friend
about order yeah so you can see the
order as someone like you you know
that's why this gesture it's like we're
creating a bridge and I become you you
know and if we close eyes like we were
still connected you know
so he met Irina Bokova and mr. and Gita
her deputy general of UNESCO the german
general of former unesco and deputy
general and he said when we talked about
what we do he said this is the future
and we really believe if you look at the
into the future using a science fiction
movie for example you look at
civilization in two hundred or a
thousand years you see different you see
aliens different shape different colors
you see robots and they're there one
collective and one community and that's
that's the goal that's where it should
good good okay so the next year is going
to be more about human connectivity and
more about getting people to do this and
to find more peace and love in their
lives and with other and other humans
and I want to just to be part of world
culture the gesture to be part of world
culture great and what is a what is a
way to do that right now besides the
Instagram selfies getting other really
people at the UN and etc involved in it
the government's talking about you
talked about I don't mention social
media we started using social media on
the selfie and although we found out
that its social media has its limits
yeah and it has it can be very
inspirational it can be it can be
marvelous and actually habits are the
big thing habits so if you get people to
start doing the gesture as part of world
culture that is the way to scale fast so
when you do the large drone shot you
know you guys have drone shots where you
have the whole community of like 100 200
300 people just doing this together in a
heart and that kind of stuff that after
that happens and they're all there to
say that hey doing this at least once a
day with someone is the best way to
propel peace and him and connectivity
through the world that is I think the if
you can get people to do it every day
once
day yeah yep this is it's like I
recently I recently started taking a
deep breath everyday like and there's
that that's a really good one then
there's you know future author and you
should write about what you want to
build into the future or feel take those
breaths and feel the future you want to
build you want to see this be a part of
global culture then to see it and feel
it and then and then know the steps that
you need to take to do it okay so making
water simple things like we met so many
different cultures and communities and
we learned from them went to the natives
and Standing Rock for example and yeah
meaner to knee water is life is so
simple things that we tend to forget we
don't agree we don't we don't go out in
nature we don't yeah I'm saying we
that's like yeah because we losing those
habits we lose those habits but when we
have other habits we gain other habits
me okay let's what we have to preside
the fact that in November 2016 we
started to in order to expand in order
to spread this gesture we started to
travel to all the 50 states yeah and to
meet people from different faith
communities skin skull like every
different season and meet also leaders
once Meyer yeah once by community and if
they can do it every day and teach
others to do every day okay so let's do
some of our our thought-provoking
questions around what we were talking
about before so with that with the
amount of time that you are spending
teaching people about collaboration and
unity and peace and human connectivity
all very important things a lot of
people have a slight fear of losing
their ego have the slight fear of losing
their individualism as well when they
hear words like collective or us they
they feel like oh no how am I like that
other person across the world so even
though it's true that we are like that
other person across the world they are
our brother or sister and our family etc
how do you guys teach people to or how
do you even have this conversation about
how I retain my individual
ilysm and my what I want to bring to the
world but also how do I bring in my
brothers and sisters into the family how
do you balance that out first of all we
creating experience how it is to be
united with people that you don't know
that's why we do what we do then Smyly
bring people together in random places
and just ask him hey connect spend a
moment together and then if you don't
know the person next to you ask their
name ask where they're from and that
makes people realize okay I was in my
own little world I was doing my thing
whatever I was doing somebody I don't
know came up I don't know where ask me
to do something to connect them to to do
a gesture it breaks the rhythm of their
life then they meet other people that
they don't know they start talking to
them it creates something that I can
that's how it could be so I'm in my own
ego world because that's what I'm that's
my habit somebody comes and breaks that
habit and actually I'm having a good
time because it makes me smile yeah and
I was like oh I mean I meet somebody
that I actually maybe like might be a
friend and I kind of like breaks it
breaks the ice of like creating the
opposite they're like the collectiveness
that we're all brothers and sisters all
the cliche kind of slogans hard to say
that are kind of outdated nowadays but
that's what it's about do you think ego
is also important for you driving to
achieve what you want in the world to
make that impact yes everybody everybody
is important and we can't be selfless
and forget about ourselves that's not
what we're about
yeah yeah exactly so you have to build
everything yourself you have to be
ground you have to know who you are
where you are yeah yeah but having this
yes we have to find that but it's
sometimes it's even easier to find it
with somebody else like the two of us
playing tennis playing ping pong then we
learn because we're sometimes we argue
sometimes we struggle but we have this
work and we and we grow by it in the
exchange exactly instead of just being
like okay I'm gonna do my thing I'm
gonna do my movies I'm gonna do my I'm
gonna do it in the experience of
collaboration you learn and I want to go
this way I would go this way but I won't
go like why I stirred different
approaches to the same thing
because there's different ways and to
learn there okay I just learned another
way so maybe I can combine these twos
way and find even a better way and the
thing is also I think we live in a
society that people cause everything go
fast people don't know how to listen
they hear they don't listen I was
talking really fast now no but it's like
this conversation you know everyone
because we we kind of are pretty sure
you want to inspire people to be good to
be happy we want that the same thing so
we have three leaders in this three
seats so talking about every one of us
every one of us wants to speak the
question is do you wait you see some
time you go to the UC you watch the TVs
and you have all this leaders try to
speak up the same time you know cut the
other one and because they don't really
listen the most all okay let's do my way
or the highway
let's do my way or the highway and
they're all talking like that leads my
way or the highway
my way the highway everybody catch each
other don't really listen sometimes it's
good to add something but you can feel
we live in a humanity everyone's two
wants to go fast in you know in you know
own way because you know this is how the
ego work you know it's like it's hard to
control the thing to be in the control
zone you know and the soul it's
different you know
Saussure care about the collective you
know like about Umberto's model about
the emotion you know and it's like you
make a movie so you are like for example
your director or your writer your editor
edit and then you you you happy about
your stuff you know you're happy like I
have myself and then you shoot the
people and I know it doesn't touch me
you bring up a very good point actually
listening verses hearings really
important being very aware of that but
also knowing when to chime in
because you want to have tennis ball
back really well so we we don't have
that much time left so I want to get
through let's chop-chop-chop-chop to get
through it now but this has been very
powerful and impactful let's see here so
first thing about collaboration
competition we were messaging about this
I think it's very interesting for you
guys to at least touch on it and it kind
of goes back to the individualism and
the collectivism but how do you think
that we should balance you know world
collaboration but also world competition
so that way people are inspired to
innovate and be capitalistic but also
collaborate with other developing parts
of the world and get them the right
tools that they need etc so how do you
guys balance that this is where I was
going to go because competition is about
ego it's about energy vitality you can
have a little bit of that right now it's
like honestly you look at yourself every
day you have a competition in design
yourself you know now the question is do
you compare to the other and you to be
better than the other all you want to be
competitive in yourself yeah to be a
p-value something really strong value
for the society Society yeah that's good
that's I like that perspective a lot so
you tune in word and you kind of compete
with yourself to become better and
better every day and then provide
something of value to the world and then
that's kind of the measuring stick when
we talk about competition we have to
define success
what is success is success if I'm the
best in my class is that success like if
everybody has a maybe success is
bringing the most value to the world
yeah success is not about success
shouldn't be defined we have to kind of
change goals and change the meaning of
success in people yeah if I'm the best
of the class but the class is really bad
and I'm just average I'm the best in the
class but what do I win what if the
whole class would be would be a a B
instead of a C and everybody would be
smarter and would learn more and would
be more advanced I wouldn't be the best
maybe but I would be better than I would
have been the best when I was just
become better as well okay last couple
questions first question is are do you
think we're alone in the cosmos
I don't think so I don't think so
actually like no I don't think so
because when you think about with so
much advanced with science and like how
can we be alone if it's so big
but then what means alone if I can't
reach a person I feel alone am I alone
or am I not alone so it's it's kind of a
I don't think so but wondering what it
comes to definition yeah Einstein said
like I don't know about the universe but
I know that stupidity is infinite you
know I'm really thinking like it's
series it's like all or nothing you know
either there's life everywhere or the
were they only yeah it's like it's
between the whole and nothing we don't
know yeah but there is a better chance
that there is infinite Lepus infinite
possibility that there is other lives do
you guys think we're in a computer
simulation mm-hmm
what is computers that's interesting
it's an extent of someone and yeah
computer and robot some people said all
there is reward every humans but some
some humans did the robots so it
actually it's a priori for pretty of the
human so what how appropriate property
you know I don't think so that's why I
think it's a very good simulation yeah
good and then last question is what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
you have people oh you're so cool you
said at the same time love yeah people
exactly human connection this has been
super fun super insightful
let's all slow down let's do some human
connectivity let's find more peace in
our lives let's everyone at home find
someone and do this with a group do the
individual do the individuals with
vample and we'd like that instead of a
handshake Ya Ya Ya Ya greet like this
great so thank you thank you and with
this you don't have to do that you know
yes yeah thank you thank you for coming
and thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in he had a good time like subscribe
comments all that good stuff thanks
Suresh round Vargas on our production
team directing thank you and talk more
soon